- Oh, Mahomes retired to play baseball? I’m just focused on getting my 20th ring.
- LAMAR! We have to go! We’re being eliminated by RYAN TANNEHILL—
- Ryan Tannehill tore his ACL three years ago. Man, we can beat the Titans in our sleep.
- Hey, man. Great job out there. You’re the future of our league.
- [Together:] AHHHHHH.
- Boo! Boo! Low Truzz! What happened?
- IT’S THE HAUNTING OF TANNEHILL HOUSE.
- Oh, we’re about to have a fun vacation getaway, eh follow young stars?
- Yeah, noted Canadian Chase Claypool.
Wait, did we all wear letterman jackets? I thought I was the jock in this crew.
- [Together:] No, I'm the jock.
- They say the ghosts of all the injured QBs left for dead live there.
But some of them find a way back.
AHH! IT’S THE BENT-NECKED MANNING.
- [Nationwide tune] I created Adam Gase.
- So you see...God damn it. When am I going to get the respect I—
- You really think these oldheads can come back and haunt us?
- Yo, it wasn’t me. Broncos don’t play lights-out.
- I’m sorry in advance. Turns out I’m good now!
- [Together:] AHHHHHH.
- OH NO...IT’S A TRAP...GAME.
- I'll take KFC sauce, and I like my extra crispy tenders boneless.
- Not cool, man.
- 100 percent white meat tenders, available now.
- SOARIE ABOOT YOUR POOR AMERICAN HEALTHCARE THERE, RYAN.
- DREW, LOCK THE DOOR.
- What about the door?
- [Together:] LOCK THE DOOR!
- Oh.
- Hello, prepare to be gone, baby. GONE.
- Hey, I’d like this one actually.
- Oh of course, Tyrod. You get whatever you want, man.
- Don’t look in the mirror. Coach Gruden says mirrors
are for rock stars and basketball players.
- For some reason, you’re the only one here I can beat.
- I found the Red Zone, eh!
- I’m not like you guys. The Cowboys are gonna take me back.
- Yeah, but do you want to go back?
- Woah...I never thought of it like that.
- Oh wait, it’s my turn.
I’M COMING FOR YOU, BUT WATCH OUT BECAUSE
I’M SUPER CONFUSING.
- Hello, Minkah.
- You—
- Hold on. I’m not actually dead. I can come back from this.
- QUIET YOU, PEOPLE STILL SOMEWHAT RESPECT ME HERE IN 2018.
- You might want to find a way out of here.
- He was a victim of Gase, just like me.
- So many wasted years...
- Woo! We're still undefeated. How weird is that?
- Sure was nice to meet ya, ghost.
- [Together:] TEAMY WANTS YOU TO SUBSCRIBE,
But Teamy also wants…
a hug.
Just because we be Team Monster
don't mean we be monster monster.
AHHHH MUST EAT TO SURVIVE!